[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález tun es la cuna
de la primavera árabe enfrenta
nuevamente un remezón político y una
crisis constitucional después de que el
presidente casi side destituyera al
primer ministro de ese país también
suspendiera la actividad del parlamento
y también cesará a los ministros de
defensa y a la ministra de justicia
estos movimientos políticos recientes a
esta joven democracia según the
economist túnez es la única nación
democrática del mundo árabe sin embargo
este país atraviesa también una profunda
crisis económica las cifras que les voy
a dar no son muy alentadoras el
desempleo juvenil solamente por darles
un ejemplo supera el 40.8 por ciento y
durante el 2019 túnez perdió el 8.8 de
su producto interno bruto también hay
que sumar otros factores el descontento
ciudadano que se ve reflejado en esas
manifestaciones multitudinarias en las
calles y que recuerda un poco a ese
descontento vivido hace diez años que
dio origen precisamente a la primavera
árabe aunque hago la aclaración que las
causas
eran muy diferentes a las actuales
también se suma la crisis sanitaria que
juega un papel muy importante con 11.6
millones de habitantes túnez ya presenta
más de 578 mil casos de contagio y más
de 19 mil personas han fallecido según
el conteo de la universidad johns
hopkins así es como están las cosas
veamos el presidente de caixa it
sostiene que todo tiene legitimidad y ha
negado las acusaciones de que su
decisión de despedir al primer ministro
y suspender al parlamento equivale a un
golpe de estado he asumido la
responsabilidad
estoy asumiendo una responsabilidad
histórica aquellos que afirman que este
asunto está relacionado con un golpe de
estado deben revisar sus lecciones en la
constitución talca no
se ha visto a la gente a no salir a las
calles prometió que cualquier oposición
violenta se enfrentaría con la fuerza y
también reforzó las restricciones de
kobe 19 en cuanto a reuniones el primer
ministro destituido y james y se acordó
dejar que el presidente eligiera su
sucesor diciendo que no quería causar
problemas más temprano el lunes
estallaron refriegas frente al
parlamento de túnez cuando los
partidarios del presidente se
enfrentaron a los partidarios del
principal partido del país las
decisiones del presidente de caixa y no
son correctas contra la constitución y
la realidad nos traen de nuevo a 1954
ver el parlamento cerrado por tanques es
una vergüenza la decisión se tomó luego
de meses de estancamiento político y
crecientes tensiones el impacto de la
pandemia junto con el alto desempleo
resultó en protestas masivas contra el
gobierno durante el fin de semana muchas
potencias extranjeras han expresado su
preocupación por las acciones del
presidente esa y instando a túnez a no
poner en peligro
gracias de 10 años
esta crisis política y constitucional en
túnez genera nerviosismo en toda la
región sobre todo en esos países vecinos
sobre todo libia y un poco más al esté
egipto países que también protagonizaron
la primavera árabe y siguen con
inestabilidad política y sin ir muy
lejos la vecina argelia está mirando muy
atentamente los hechos en túnez porque
allí también hay un alto descontento por
parte de los ciudadanos hay también una
alta desaprobación de la clase política
en conclusión hay un especial interés en
cada uno de los pasos que está dando
túnez que lleve a mantener esta joven
democracia y a garantizar los derechos
de los ciudadanos y así evitar caer en
un espiral de inestabilidad para
analizar este tema hasta con nosotros
desde la ciudad de perpiñán en el sur de
francia
killani pensar él es historiador
escritor ex militar tunecino también es
especialista en derecho internacional
humanitario y también está con nosotros
el señor jose m edin que ya él es
profesor asociado de historia moderna de
la universidad de sfax
y también es miembro del laboratorio de
patrimonio de la universidad mon uva en
túnez luego ustedes me corregirá con mía
árabe se pronuncia correctamente los
nombres de las instituciones y sus
nombres ustedes también nuestros
televidentes son parte de esta
conversación a través de las redes
sociales y ustedes pueden dejar todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de la cuenta en facebook y también en
twitter e instagram nos encuentra como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
pueden dejar los comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos
un poco más claro el el contexto y
comienzo preguntándole a aquilani
nuestro primer invitado sobre los hechos
que han ocurrido recientemente allí en
este país africano
desde su punto de vista si hubo un golpe
de estado que es lo que acusa allí la
oposición política del presidente de ese
país
1 si la posición ya piensa que es un
golpe de estado pero el pueblo y de
ahora hacía mucho tiempo especialmente
últimamente cuando el presidente se ha
ido a unas ciudades pidió de la
disolución del parlamento y todas estas
medidas que el presidente tuvo son
medidas ya
a medida que con las cosas que el pueblo
pedía y hace mucho tiempo si el señor
jose en su opinión no hubo un golpe de
estado hay un mal manejo de la
constitución sobre todo de ese
controvertido artículo 80 de la
constitución tunecina que piensa usted
a mí no me parece que es un golpe de
estado hablar de un golpe de estado dice
que los militares van con el poder pero
este es un presidente que está
utilizando su autoridad y analizar la
constitución bueno hay una gran
discusión sobre el artículo 80 la
utilización de este artículo pero hablar
de un golpe de estado también me parece
que está estamos van muy largo en este
punto la posición y en las medias está
exprimiendo en libertad la libertad me
parece que hasta hoy después tres o
cuatro días de estas medidas está
garantizada entonces hablar de un golpe
de estado así en el mundo
y usted ya despejando entonces este
punto de vista sobre el posible golpe
estado ya quedan claras las opiniones de
los dos
mantengámonos entonces en ese
controvertido artículo 80 de la
constitución que autoriza el presidente
a tomar medidas necesarias como usted lo
dice si hay peligro inminente que
amenace las instituciones de la nación o
la seguridad de la independencia del
país sin embargo este artículo dice que
esa posibilidad debe ser consultada con
el jefe de gobierno con el presidente
del parlamento algo que no ha ocurrido
en este caso y que el tribunal
constitucional debe supervisar ese
proceso y el tribunal constitucional no
ha sido constituido no existe esa
institución todavía en túnez después de
que fue reformada la carta magna hay
entonces una violación de la
constitución de ese artículo 80 de
verdad túnez está en un peligro
inminente que es el argumento que da el
presidente said como lo ve usted
bueno no soy un especialista de la
constitución pero cuando decida las
medidas necesarias pues el presidente
está utilizando este como son estos
todos son medidas necesarias en este y
en esta situación bueno me parece que la
este es una discusión más de leyes de
constitución la situación en túnez es
más política entonces me parece que todo
el debate tiene que ser sobre este
asunto el asunto político y responder a
la pregunta cómo hemos llegado a este
punto porque lo que pasa en dunas no es
son resultados de un día o tres días
después desde el después las elecciones
de 2019 estamos en una crisis permanente
hasta llegamos a aquí hoy
sí claro que sí eso lo que vamos a
tratar de entender que lo que está
pasando en túnez me parecía importante
referirnos a este tema de la
constitución porque hay varios
organismos internacionales han comentado
sobre la importancia de garantizar que
se respete en la constitución tunecina
guilani cuál es su opinión para terminar
de analizar este tema de la constitución
y el artículo 80 yo ya daba los puntos
básicos a los que se refiere este punto
y también la perspectiva del presidente
que él dice que el país son medidas
necesarias porque hay un peligro
inminente de verdad túnez está ante un
peligro inminente de caer en una espiral
de inestabilidad o en un conflicto
interno o en más inestabilidad política
como lo ve usted
claro que sí y túnez ya hace mucho
tiempo que estaba en peligro y el
presidente ha sufrido mucho y tenía
mucha paciencia y se sabe en el mundo
creo que era con los ejércitos son los
garantes de la constitución y de la
independencia del país entonces él es el
país
utilizan sus medios ya que están entre
sus manos como jefe supremo de las
fuerzas armadas de túnez y egipto el
mínimo para mí para para como decir
bloquear la situación para no tener para
tu no dañar más la sociedad durísima y
para mí es que esta medida es
constitucional porque porque la mayoría
de los juristas
y declare como decir la sociedad civil y
muchos países y aceptar y nunca como
diría
hablan de cómo se llama de golpe de
estado porque olvides de hadas una vez
una exageración con exageración porque
los socios son unas unos militares con
una camiones pequeños para controlar
para controlar las calles para para
impedir que se acercan del parlamento y
no violencia al contrario el presidente
y salvó el país porque desde 2002 estaba
en parís y volvía a túnez para para
aprovechar de la de la sanidad y de la
huida del presidente ben alí y un año
más ya volví a francia porque esto que
es un engaño a todo el pueblo están
engañando de 100 años estelar los
islamistas y tuvieron una ocasión de oro
para mostrar que la religión es buena
pero anna han sacrificado todo
cómo explicarlo por de verdad la nuevos
islamistas ya son una o una unión ha
conseguido un árbol negro en la historia
de túnez y el pueblo ya las lecturas ha
perdido todo túnez todas las empresas
nacionales no funcionan y ellos ya
tenían contini de segunda mano ahora
leer cada uno de unos tiene como mínimo
dos coches ya de de cien mil cien
millones de euros de dónde viene el
dinero de esos cien años se ha gastado
por ellos y que no tenía ningún nivel
ahora el gobierno y todos los estados
dentro lo vigente y para milán ya no
tenían en general yo diría de verdad que
es una ansiedad ha sido la ocasión para
para los islamistas demostrar que tenía
razón pero ahora no tiene ninguna cuando
estaba intentando llamar
si usted toca un punto que le quería
preguntar desde hace rato y es
precisamente qué es lo que ha atravesado
en el camino después de la primavera
árabe después de que hay ese rompimiento
político y se establece una democracia
en túnez que es lo que no ha funcionado
en túnez que ha que lleve a que esa
democracia se consolide y que el país
salga adelante económicamente porque
hemos visto manifestaciones de los
ciudadanos en las calles que están en
desacuerdo con las medidas descontentos
porque su calidad de vida ha disminuido
llega a la crisis sanitaria que complica
aún más la situación social y hay un
flujo grande de tunecinos tratando de
llegar a europa para mejorar sus
condiciones de vida el país no les está
garantizando un buen nivel de vida que
es lo que le falló entonces a esta
revolución
lo que no funcionó son gente como vamos
si usted quiere que un panadero
como decía un panadero enseña la la la
la la matemática la matemática como uno
sea una un agricultor ya hacia el
trabajo de panadero ellos no son
profesionales y nada bueno ya estaban en
las cárceles seguro pero en el cáncer
van a aprender nada pero por lo menos no
deben ser cabezones y poner el instituto
sólo la gente que le gusta no por hacer
el bien al l al país a la patria pero no
para para conseguir como decir de
provechos personales y provechosos para
para la comunidad porque para ellos esto
es como es común wood grita en francés
no sé si se dificulta por algo que se
gana después de ganar la guerra para
ellos lunes ha sido así hay que
aprovechar el máximo y ahora
la mayoría de ellos es lo que hicieron
entonces lo que no funcionó es todo de
verdad porque la libertad de expresión
esto es un engaño es una no es nada
imaginativo que una familia y todo el
mundo tiene la libertad y todo el mundo
está saliendo día y noche pero claro
justo aquí hay un punto importante
ustedes lo mencionaban en otras de sus
respuestas y es el apoyo que le han dado
los tunecinos a la decisión del
presidente eso es un respaldo importante
eso da garantías pero estos cambios que
ha determinado el presidente que ha sido
criticado por muchos organismos
internacionales pero es apoyado por el
pueblo tunecino cree usted que es el
punto de partida para reformar el país
para empezar un camino enrutado hacia la
prosperidad de los ciudadanos
bueno la verdad yo tengo muchas muchas
dudas y también podríamos decir en mí
pero como acabo de decir usted casi 86
por ciento de la población está con él
el presidente y la verdad en túnez
después diez años necesitamos este
pudimos decir este este cambio
porque después diez años es y me pareció
otro quiero volver a otro punto que
tiene parece túnez no pueden ver volver
atrás la democracia me parece ahora en
túnez es algo que el pueblo tunecino
jamás van van a perder la democracia y
la libertad de expresión porque tenemos
casi una generación de tiempo faltan
abrieron sus ojos en la demografía y la
libertad también otro punto que que
ahora en túnez del conflicto no están 3
laicas
entre la gente que quiere la verdadera
democracia y contra la corrupción porque
el pueblo tunecino cuando salió el
domingo pasado no han utilizado ningún
título algo que controlar el islam
político pero todo contra la corrupción
dentro entonces contraen nada y los
otros partidos como algunos y los otros
los inicios políticos casi todos que
empiezan están gobernando tú si de
verdad hay muchos muchas dudas sobre la
constitución y todo esto pero al mundo a
todo el mundo tiene que entender que el
pueblo tunecino está viviendo en una
situación muy mal y después ponen curry
disney 19 casi cada día murieron fueron
más de 200 personas cada día
económica muy complicada entonces
necesitamos este cambio de tú no puedes
imaginar la felicidad del pueblo y la
esperanza volvió la esperanza a este
pueblo pero josemi desde su punto de
vista esta coyuntura deja en juego
entonces la democracia tunecina o es un
paso necesario para consolidar la porque
desde el punto de vista internacional y
lo que vemos desde el otro lado del
atlántico desde aquí desde américa
latina es que la democracia está en
riesgo está en riesgo entonces la
democracia qué opina usted
mi opinión estoy casi seguro que la
democracia no está en ningún riesgo este
es un punto necesario yo historiador y
conozco bien lo que un poco lo que pasa
en europa en el siglo 19 siempre hay
esté un poco cambio o retraso detrás y
luego la democracia consolida la
consolidada entonces siempre ante la
situación económica porque es el auxilio
sin la mejorar de la situación económica
del pueblo tunecino la democracia jamás
va a consolidar entonces ojalá aquí con
estas decisiones del presidente y que
las cosas económicas va a cambiar
killani quiero conocer su opinión sobre
este mismo punto sobre si está en juego
la democracia tunecina y le pongo dos
escenarios uno que esto sirva para
consolidar y fortalecer los cimientos de
la democracia de este país norafricano o
que exista el riesgo que personajes como
el presidente esa y quieran perpetuarse
en el poder porque hemos visto
completamente las dos caras de la moneda
hemos visto que por ejemplo países que
han pasado por revoluciones similares a
la primavera árabe que atravesó túnez
caso libia se desató un conflicto
interno acaso egipto llegó un gobierno
dictatorial a asumir las riendas y por
las garantías de derechos humanos y de
democracia pues están en entredicho
túnez tiene al frente de estos dos
escenarios para usted no está en riesgo
en juego
l la democracia si es una es un logro
muy importante y que quiero decir que el
presidente de saic dijo
dejó abierto un poco será sólo un mes
sólo un mes para probar para ver si es
que sé que será la reacción del partido
que está que tiene mejores
los números en el parlamento y así pues
se puede pero yo veo que tiene el
partido a nada advertido de una
mayoritario en el parlamento él no tiene
ninguna idea para para como decir para
que sí que sea una a un nuevo alguien
que está construyendo en el partido nada
está destruyendo porque como decía antes
no tenía profesionales y no tenía buena
intención es que si usted lo que están
escuchando si le gusta ver una urna en
el sitio del sitio como decir lo más
importante también se juega la
democracia es el parlamento este
parlamento volvió a ser un ring ring de
de peleas y utilizando sus manos y como
decir hacer elecciones secretas
y lo que es están en la oposición están
como perros ya no quieren aceptar a sus
opiniones éste debe cambiar porque
vosotros ya tenéis esta opinión pero el
pueblo tunecino estaba sufriendo hace
mucho tiempo y no es había sólo la forma
de la democracia pero dentro ya hay allí
allá hay hay señores para no decir otra
palabra exteriores dentro del parlamento
que no que no tiene ningún escrúpulo que
no sé que están ahí para para jugar o
para parar para pelear desde sus ideas
desde la calle son gente de la calle lo
juro hay mucha gente que están
silenciosas y no quieren hablar de lo
que está pasando pero hay miles
pero pero a simple vista lo que uno ve
es que es un parlamento muy fraccionado
hay casi 30 diferentes formaciones
políticas allí y da la impresión que esa
es una de las dificultades para lograr
consensos para poder sacar adelante
leyes y modificaciones que son
necesarias en ese país pero de acuerdo a
lo que usted nos está diciendo no es no
es tanto la fragmentación política que
tiene el parlamento sino las diferencias
en los puntos de opinión y en que la
gente que está en el parlamento no es la
gente adecuada entonces quien los eligió
el pueblo tunecino no
sí pero de él pero pero para volver otra
vez que quieras la máquina de elección
la máquina para llamarla darle los
electores tunecinos no ha sido una
máquina honesta ha sido la el dinero
negro el delay y cosas así de corrupción
pero porque si no ya se siente seguro
que has visto que la mayoría como 80 por
ciento de la verdad el pueblo filipino
está al lado de la de la presidencia y
por qué porque bueno si él en el breve
el partido de la amistad le dio mucho
dinero y ofreció mucho dinero para todos
estar ofreciendo dinero para cualquier
cosa porque para él está solucionando
las situaciones de su situación por no
tener gente el profesional con el dinero
está pasando el dinero del tesoro de
túnez ha pagado millones y millones de
euros diciendo que son preparaciones de
reparación explique a los que
combatieron en las montañas no sé y la
gente que trabaja
los de la patria no lo harán nunca
pidieron algo sus hijos
no piden nada entonces
hemos visto que estos han sido algunos
de los esos primeros pasos que ha dado
el presidente es que otros movimientos a
nivel político pueden estar bajo la
manga o en la mesa del presidente para
tratar de solucionar esta crisis
política que más movimientos podemos ver
ahí
aquí decir a ustedes movimientos
movimientos decisiones a decisiones
estratégicas a nivel político por
ejemplo acercarse a la oposición o
seguir muy apegado a lo que le dice la
constitución y el pueblo la posición que
pueda tomar el presidente con
instituciones importantes como por
ejemplo el ejército de túnez
bueno la verdad la situación muy
complicada para mí no puedo ver como en
30 días
el presidente iba a [__] todas las
decisiones necesarias y el parlamento va
a volver a trabajar a mí no sé cómo éste
va a pasar me parece estamos de verdad
en un vamos a entrar una crisis
constitucional porque el presidente va
para adelante
en esas decisiones no va a volver detrás
a mí me parece que esto no es posible
también hoy hay cambios en lo en las
declaraciones de los actores políticos
en túnez de hay gente que el primero
está en contra de las decisiones del
presidente y hoy han cambiado su opinión
también el partido del partido de nada
es tan está cambiando su discurso y
ahora habla un poco a poco tenemos de
volver al diálogo tenemos que el
presidente tiene pues me parece las
cosas la verdad no son claras y no sé
cómo va
esto me parece un tipo importante para
esa estabilización es la posición que ha
tenido la oposición política usted
mencionaba que han comentado el día de
hoy que están abiertos al diálogo de
hecho ya hay registro en algunos medios
internacionales que aceptan estas
elecciones
anticipadas para poder evitar que el
país caiga en una espiral de crisis
política esto es un escenario favorable
para poder salir de la crisis como vería
usted esas elecciones sería un momento
crítico para la nación sin duda alguna
como podría haber usted a futuro jugando
aquí un poco con la bola de cristal no
si primero me parece que el presidente y
también la mayoría de la gente aquí no
van a aceptar una elección con el mismo
ley electoral
el primero entonces tenemos que cambiar
el ley electoral porque hay mucho
fracaso de partidos también cómo ha
funcionado usted hay mucho mucho dinero
negro entonces todo esto tiene que
cambiar pero cómo vamos a cambiar todo
esto bajo el stick constes constitución
me parece que la solución eso con un
diálogo nacional pero esta vez un
verdadero diálogo nacional que también
tiene la uti que la gente
[Música]
tienen que cambiar sus opiniones tipo
redes por el bueno de todo el pueblo
tenía sino a ser
y le pregunto ahora aquilani piensa
usted que primero debe haber esta mesa
de diálogo antes de llegar a esas
elecciones hacer una modificación a la
ley electoral para garantizar unas
elecciones mucho más transparentes y
mucho más representativas para los
ciudadanos que piensan
si las direcciones serán unas a una
buena salida para túnez en general pero
yo espero de todo corazón que el
presidente no lo utiliza este este plazo
de 30 días para pensar que todo será
resuelto todo lo que habrá soluciones de
milagro al final de el mes de digamos de
agosto y para decir 'no a la luz como
militar
jubilado del ejército donde el lunes yo
todavía siempre he pensado que era el
ejército de túnez es la institución que
se quedó a política y eficaz y garante
para la constitución pero para hablar de
como decir después de pasar esta esta
situación ya que habrá que hacer habrá
mucho que hay que cambiar porque todo en
el cuerpo de la nación está donde está
hecho de corrupción entonces no van a no
es seguro que no van a parar a proponer
recientes de miles de gente en la cárcel
pero es la situación y espero que
también los países que no aquí están los
países extranjeros extranjeros no
complican la situación de túnez porque
hablando así de reconocía el presidente
ya su juris está ahí es un señor de
buena voluntad y no tiene y no lo que
dice de honor ahora es mi amigo pero yo
sí
tengo la sensación y lo que dice todo el
mundo que es una señora
y está haciendo su posible para sacarnos
de esta miseria perdona la palabra si
precisamente la campaña anticorrupción
fue el tema abanderado de su campaña
política de su campaña presidencial y es
el tema que prácticamente lo llevó a la
silla presidencial fue el tema que
cautivó a los tunecinos y que por eso le
dieron una votación cercana al 70 por
ciento en esas elecciones presidenciales
ilegal le garantizaron llegar a la
jefatura del estado tunecino y pues esto
según sus argumentos es parte de esa
campaña anticorrupción para el cierre
rápidamente de minutos tengo muy pocos
minutos pero quiero preguntarle entonces
a josean rápidamente qué va a suceder en
los próximos días 50 segundos su
panorama claro de lo que sucede en el
país
me parece el destino de titulares el
diálogo entre todos los partidos las
organizaciones pero también en esta vez
me parece que los jóvenes tienen que
participar directamente a este diálogo
aquilani su opinión la presencia
internacional es nos van a ayudar a
túnez para porque estos partidos otros
partidos de la oposición para ponerse en
la posición contra el señor están y van
a dificultar y complicar las soluciones
al presidente es mi opinión pues
aquilani ven a pensar y josé medín
ezzati a muchas gracias por su opinión
por haber compartido con nosotros su
punto de vista sobre esta situación que
se está viviendo en túnez una realidad
muy alejada de américa latina pero que
queríamos traer aquí al debate france24
para conocer y para hacerle seguimiento
a esa transformación política que está
viviendo ese país norafricano ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]